good evening welcome very minor quick at
the name at Claremont McKenna College it
is my pleasure tonight to introduce
professor Francis Fukuyama Francis
Fukuyama has dedicated his career to
studying and writing about how culture
and society have adjusted to modern
politics and economics one of the most
acclaimed and controversial writers of
our time Fukuyama's first book at the
end of history at the end of history in
the last man was the best seller in four
countries and has appeared in over 20
foreign editions his second book trusts
the social virtues and the creation of
prosperity has similar success and was
named business week's book of the year
last year he published a new book the
great disruption human nature and the
reconstitution of social order
currently the Hearst professor of public
policy at George Mason University and
the director of its institute of public
policies international commerce and
policy program
Fukuyama previously served in the
political science department of the RAND
Corporation and the policy planning
staff the u.s. Department of State
please join the Henry Salvatori Center
and the Athenaeum and welcoming to
Claremont McKenna College one of the
most distinguished social thinkers of
our era mr. Francis Fukuyama
all right another time with feeling
I really am delighted to be here back at
Claremont and I'm particularly grateful
to the Athenaeum and to Charles Kessler
and the Salvatori Center for having
invited me Charles and I are old friends
and I'm really extremely happy to see
him and others that I know well at this
in this College the the word
controversial I think is probably right
I was here in Southern California a
little over a year ago debating the
barbra streisand professor of Gender
Studies at USC on the question of the
fate of the American family and was
attacked quite strongly from the left
and I was recently shown an article
written by a conservative Catholic
scholar entitled Fukuyama as teacher of
evil now I don't know whether this means
that I'm stirring up healthy debate or
I'm actually just really so blindly
middle-of-the-road that nobody can find
anything of worth in in what I say but I
do want to touch on I think what are
some of the major social and moral
issues that have convulsed not just our
society but many other societies over
the past generation and what I call the
great disruption and it's a story about
the decline and I believe the rise of
social order there has been a huge
change in moral values in social norms
that govern the way that people relate
to each other in modern societies and I
believe that many of those changes that
have occurred over the past 30 or 40
years in fact were very problematic ones
that that led to societies being able to
do things less effectively in terms of
raising children producing goods and
services and in acting as a political
community and so in some sense
conservatives are right when they talk
about moral decline but I think it's
also the case that the explanations that
are given for why this happened leave
something to be desired and moreover it
seems to me that the trend is really not
one of secular decline from some period
where moral values were
were inevitably better but in fact
follows a more cyclical kind of rhythm
that this was in fact a disruption that
was driven by certain forces but in a
sense is in the process of healing and
so part of the message is in a certain
sense an Aristotelian one that I think
that we went through a period that we
have discussed in in what have been
called the culture wars in in our
society a great moral uncertainty but
that there are reasons for thinking that
we're going out of this period now that
societies are becoming our society and
other societies are becoming more
orderly and what I'd like to do is after
describing this great disruption to talk
a little bit on a kind of more
philosophical plane about where social
order comes from because I think in a
sense we have within us and as a part of
our natural Constitution a certain
desire for order that in a sense will
tend to correct these problems as they
happen now before I go on I want to
define one concept which is critical to
my framework which is the concept of
social capital social capital is a term
that has been used by social scientists
in the last 10 or 15 years to you know
it's a you can think of it as a kind of
utilitarian understanding of the
importance of culture and it's important
to think of it in those terms because of
the legacy of cultural relativism we
tend to think of cultural values as kind
of arbitrary rules that vary from one
society to another and it's impossible
to make judgments as to what is better
and what is worse but in fact social
capital is the or values and shared
culture more generally is the basis of
social cooperation in any society and as
virtually anything in economics and
politics depends on the cooperation of
more than one individual it is the key
to both successful liberal democracy and
to modern economic development and
therefore there's a cultural element to
all of our modern societies that we need
to pay attention to we need to look to
the sources of social capital where
people can actually work together
cooperatively in in groups and
associations to promote various
causes gentlemen my table it introduced
me have just been to Washington at the
the IMF World Bank meetings and you know
that is an example in a certain sense of
civil society in action the ability of
people to associate for for political
ends and that is I think actually
critical to the success of democracy so
we have to worry about this tendency or
the ability to to cooperate now what was
the great disruption in a sense this is
the playing out of a lot of the themes
that have been around ever since the
beginning of the Enlightenment and it
reflects in a way the dilemma of liberal
individualism the Enlightenment was
designed to set people free from
tradition from obscurantist religion
from a lot of irrational traditions that
had bound them to families to workplaces
to to political units and the idea you
know in essence the the modern project
was based on the idea that individuals
should be free to choose all of those
attachments voluntarily and to create a
society based on rational Association
for ends that people chose themselves
and the political expression of this was
of course a modern liberal democracy the
problem as any number of social critics
like Alistair McIntyre Peter Peter
Berger and others had pointed out is
that that liberal individualism tends to
run to an extreme that undermines the
possibility for any form of community
whatsoever so that even the kinds of
voluntary associations that we enter
into marriages employ employment even
citizenship in national units tends
itself to be a weakened because the
strength of our attachments is in a
sense hollowed out by a belief in the
primacy of the individual over the
various communities and forms of
authority to which individuals are
subject now I believe that you can
document this decline of community and
community authority and the rise of
liberal individualism in any number of
ways in my book I actually picked three
of them which have to do with
and you can think of them in a certain
sense as negative measures of social
capital if social capital our shared
values that allow people to cooperate
productively in groups then in a certain
sense crime family breakdown and the
rise of social distrust would all be
empirical indicators statistics that
would tell you that people were less
able to cooperate in the basic
institutions that made up a society I
began this project maybe four or five
years ago collecting data on these three
categories you could pick others you
could pick you know something like
litigation drug abuse suicide rates and
and others I have certain reasons for
focusing on these because the data was
available it was good for the set of
countries that I wanted to look at and
the like but what really struck me
putting all of this together was that
there was a phenomenon that was broad
and extended across societies and was
very concentrated in time that in a
sense begged a certain explanation for
example crime rates we are all aware of
in the United States started to rise in
the approximately in the mid 1960s up
until the early 1990s and most Americans
I'm sure where that American crime rates
are significantly higher than those in
other industrialized countries what many
Americans don't understand is a crime
rates even though starting from a lower
position in in countries like Sweden or
the United Kingdom or Italy also rose at
a very rapid rate over pretty much the
same time period and in fact for the
group of countries that I looked at
which are the developed countries in the
OECD except for the Asian members that
is to say Japan and Korea if you look at
their charts they all move pretty much
in the same direction at the same time
as in the United States the number of
them that experienced these large
increases in crime have come down in
some cases fairly dramatically in the
1990s but that's a story resolved for
later in the speech similarly if you put
together statistics on family and
kinship you see them moving again in a
similar direction fertility drops
very dramatically to sub-replacement
levels in the post-war period to the
point that most and if you say that the
basic role of the family is to promote
reproduction there's not very much that
going on in the developed world the
total fertility rate in a country like
Italy or Germany is down to about 1.1 or
1.2 which means they lose 30 percent of
their population over the next
generation and there's been furthermore
arise I think that other people are
familiar with in things like divorce
children growing up in single-parent
families and the like and again this is
not unique to the United States in
Sweden there well in the United States
about a third of all children currently
are born to single mothers in Sweden
that number is is double two-thirds
although it's a little bit different in
Europe because there's such a high rate
of cohabitation that actually a lot of
those children are growing up in
households with their biological parents
but given the instability of family
relations which is is as far as anyone
can tell just as high in Europe as in
the United States and the substitution
of cohabitation for marriage it's very
clear that very very major changes are
going on in what is by most accounts the
most basic social institution in society
finally you get to the issue of trust
there's no good way of measuring levels
of trust our surveys like the world
value survey that's done at the
University of Michigan that tries to ask
people who whom they trust or what kind
of trust they have in various
institutions and again it's quite
remarkable over this same period there
was a decline in trust particularly for
traditional sources of authority like
the government the police the
bureaucracy the civil service political
parties and the like that again covered
pretty much the same group of countries
now the big issue and I think that you
know in in saying this probably the only
new thing that I'm telling a lot of you
is that this was going on outside of the
United States because I think that any
American who has lived through this
period was aware that there is all of
this social turmoil going on but the
fact that it was going on in other
societies I think implies certain things
about how we can interpret the causes of
it
because Americans tend to be somewhat
parochial they say well we had this big
rise of family breakdown and crime and
so forth which was due to things
happening in American history of Vietnam
Watergate Reaganism I mean everyone's
got their own list of things that
promote distrust and and social social
conflict but if that's in fact the case
it does not explain why this was
happening in New Zealand or Iceland or
any number of other countries that also
experienced this kind of decrease in in
social capital and and and social order
and I think that in many ways a lot of
the existing explanations for that are
out there that have been put up by both
liberals and conservatives capture part
of the truth but really only part of the
truth when you look at the phenomenon as
a larger whole let me begin with the
liberal interpretation of of what went
on I think many people on the Left when
the great disruption began to happen in
the 1960s when crime and family
breakdown began to accelerate at first
simply denied that there was a problem
they would say things like well you know
what is a family anyhow the Jimmy Carter
had a commission on the family that met
and broke up in disagreement because
people said well we can't simply you
know we we don't know what a family is
you know maybe a single-parent family is
just as good a family as a two-parent
family and the like by the 1980s it
seems to me it was too hard to ignore
the fact that these social indicators
were moving in a very negative direction
with a lot of consequences in terms of
welfare and poverty and a lot of other
social interrelated social pathologies
but I think the typical explanation for
this on the left has been that this is
the product of economic inequality or
absent economic opportunities or the
like now there's clearly an economic
basis and in fact my own interpretation
borrows to some extent from that but I
think that the crude form of this simply
does not you know stand a basic and
caracal test because among other things
it doesn't explain why this was going on
in a place like Sweden
the typical answer on on the part of the
left was you know the United States did
not have a big enough welfare state to
buffer poor people against job loss and
economic change and the like which would
imply that all of the social democratic
states in Scandinavia that did do this
should not be suffering from this but as
I indicated before that for example the
rate of family breakdown was as in many
ways as great in Scandinavia in a
country like Sweden as it was in the
United States conversely countries like
Switzerland or Japan which have the
lowest or smallest state sectors of any
industrialized countries actually
suffered the least from from a lot of
these problems and so there's no obvious
correlation between social programs
designed to aid or ameliorate the
problem and and the final outcomes now
there are I think really two
conservative interpretations of this
conservative interpretation number one
was in a way the mirror image of the
liberal interpretation which was to say
it was the state that was involved but
in a negative sense and this was the
this was the interpretation that was put
forward by charles murray in his book a
losing ground that came out in the early
1980s where he argued that it was
actually the welfare state itself that
was promoting family breakdown and crime
by being you know soft on crime and by a
program like eight two families with
dependent children subsidizing a
legitimacy you lose your welfare benefit
if you marry the father of your child if
you're a poor woman and and so forth and
I think that this was in fact a major
theme in American politics it was one of
the motives for Congress passing the
personal opera sponsibility and work
opportunity reconciliation Act of 1996
which was otherwise known as the big
welfare reform act it abolished the AFDC
entitlement that was passed by the
Republican Congress and signed by
President Clinton because the feeling
was that our social policy was actually
contributing to the very problem that it
was meant to solve having been through
you know the raft of econometric studies
that had been done that try to link
afdc to family breakdown I think that
you can say that it was a factor but not
the most important most of these studies
show that something like 15% of the
variance in a family breakdown could
have been attributable to American
welfare policy more than that and
furthermore if you look at the totality
of what was going on in Western families
at this time it's clear that welfare
policy couldn't begin to explain why
there was so much cohabitation in place
of marriage by professional and and
well-to-do couples were getting divorced
why there was so much turmoil in the
American family conservative explanation
number two is in a circumstance more
powerful and that explanation laid these
changes primarily to the door of culture
and there are many different versions of
this one I mean this is a something of a
caricature but you know a lot of
conservatives will say well people just
went crazy in the 1960s you had this
thing's counterculture where people
decided that they're gonna throw off you
know every form of obligation and and
community responsibility and this was
linked to secular humanism or the
decline of religion or traditional
values or something of the sort now and
and conversely to them it implies that
the solution to these problems is simply
a recovery of those kinds of traditional
values that existed at the time prior to
the great disruption now in a certain
sense I think it is indisputable that
there was a cultural basis or background
for all of this stuff happening as I
said in in many respects the kind of
expression of individual assertion self
assertion against community authority is
in a sense embedded in modern liberalism
and embedded in the whole set of modern
Enlightenment institutions that have
been with us for the last 300 years but
that's precisely the problem with this
as an explanation for why this all
happens in the 1960s because in fact if
these ideas have been in the air for the
last 300 years why did it happen
in such a concentrated time across this
particular set of countries in the late
20
century why didn't it happen you know in
fact there was a mini feminist and
sexual revolution that took place in the
1920s why didn't it blossom into
something broader or why did it have to
wait until the 1960s and 70s to really
take root and so I don't and and in the
case of the liberal account and in the
case of both of the conservative
accounts I think that there is an
element of truth in all of them but as
total explanations for this interrelated
set of events I think that there is
something that is that they leave to be
desired and and and in particular with
regard to the timing you know the ratio
for example of divorced married people
increases fourfold in a 25 year period
during the great disruption if you think
about it in terms of general cultural
change that's an enormous shift in
indicators and there are very few
societies other than very rapidly
developing third world countries where
you get similar shifts in deeply rooted
kinds of cultural patterns and and ob8
behavioral habits now my explanation
that I put forward in in the book is
that this really has to do very broadly
with factors not related to American
history and American politics not simply
to a general loss of traditional values
but really by several technological and
economic forces that began to get
underway as part of the general shift
from the industrial era into what was
once called by Daniel Bell the
post-industrial age and now we probably
refer to more commonly as the
Information Age of the information
society this is a society in which in
essence mental labor replaces at the
margin of physical labor in which
knowledge becomes far more important as
a component of of physical output in
which information is really embedded in
all of the material products that we
that we use and manufacture and it had a
whole series of important technological
and
the social ramifications let's take just
the example of crime in a certain sense
to produce an information society you
need intensive individualism it's not a
an accident that Silicon Valley in many
respects is the most competitive and in
certain ways socially atomized parts of
the country with people in you know
leaving companies and no loyalty and
intense competition and it's not
surprising that you celebrate that kind
of rule breaking and individualism you
know you you celebrate Steve Jobs and
Steve Wozniak for designing the Apple
Computer and launching this big
revolution against IBM and the like but
as my colleague at George Mason Seymour
Martin Lipset constantly points out
American individualism is an element of
American exceptionalism that is a
two-edged sword the same person that
does not want to obey the authority of
IBM or AT&T has a counterpart in the you
know the street criminal that doesn't
want to obey the laws of society as he
robs you of your wallet on your way home
from work and in a sense those are two
you know counterparts of the same coin
that the same that there's a good form
of individualism that we celebrate in
terms of technological innovation and a
bad form of individualism that we
celebrate in or we don't celebrate that
we deplore in terms of various forms of
social deviance it's not an accident
that the United States both has the
highest rate of technological innovation
and and you know especially in this past
decade economic growth when compared to
a place like Europe but also highest
rates of divorce of crime of especially
violent crime and other sorts of things
because it reflects the you know the
greater individualism embedded in in our
political values and I think in many
respects this shift to the Information
Age was one of many factors that
accelerated that and had ramifications
in areas like crime in the case of the
family there's a very specific story in
my view that explains why you have these
very dramatic changes in the family that
have to do with - and again if you
remember what you really have to do is
explain why it begins to happen in the
1960s not.you know that that it happens
at all and in my account it really is
due to two separate things as I said the
essence of the Information Age is the
substitution of mental for physical
labor the single most important social
consequence of that was the movement of
millions of women across the van
industrialized world into the paid labor
force and out of and out of households
and I think that it is not surprising
this was obviously an extremely
important social event it created
enormous opportunities for women but it
would be very surprising if it did not
have very destabilizing impact on
families given the traditional role that
women played in families prior to prior
to the great disruption this is not a
quirky theory on my part this is I think
kind of the standard you know
neoclassical economic explanation for
why people get divorced at all you know
there's certain degree of tension in any
marriage relationship but in a certain
sense it's dependent on the woman having
sufficient resources to to make it on on
her own the welfare state for poor women
provided those resources but for
middle-class and-and-and well-to-do
women it was their entry into into the
labor force that that was the permissive
condition for for what happened
the second technological development
that I think occurred at this period was
the birth control pill which I think was
is underestimated in its importance in
its effect on on social norms the birth
control pill was a very contradictory
innovation because by divorcing sex and
reproduction it was supposed to lead to
the liberation of women and in fact was
followed in the United States and other
countries by the sudden explosion of
divorce single-parent families women
trying to raise children on their own so
the question is you know why why did
that happen and I think the simple
answer is that the birth control pill
liberated men rather than women it had
this counterproductive or unanticipated
consequence that having come of age you
know in the 1960s I can
test two as a result of my personal
observation and experience there was in
the in the early 1960s there was an
institution known as the shotgun wedding
George Akerlof and Janet Yellen this
husband-and-wife economic team of
economists did a fascinating study a
couple of years ago that was published
in the quarterly Journal of economics
about shotgun weddings in which they
actually have some empirical data on the
rate of shotgun marriages and as late as
the 1960s according to their data is
something like 60% of all white brides
in the United States were basically
pregnant at the altar which indicates
that young people back in in the good
old 50s were having just as much
premarital sex as ever but what really
was different was that the boys that got
them pregnant were being forced through
social pressure and maybe not literally
shotguns but through other kinds of
social pressure - you know as as a
phrase was at that time to do the right
thing and to marry them now this may you
know well not have led to happy
marriages or or you know had produced
dysfunctional families but at least it
meant that the male males resources were
were being applied you know to to the
maintenance of families and I think the
single most important social norm that
changed in that period was really this
norm of male responsibility which by I
think the 19th the end of the 1960s in a
way had almost completely disappeared
with the you know many of the
consequences that we see now and in a
sense the background for this is is one
that that one would in a sense think was
natural just from what we know about the
biology of human reproduction that is to
say it seems pretty clear that the bond
between mothers and their children is a
deeply natural one it is very difficult
to find a human society and indeed it's
very hard to find an animal species in
which females do not play that role and
do not have that very strong bond with
their children and the fact that you see
this across human cultures makes you
suspect that it's something other than a
socially constructed
kind of behavior on the part of women on
the other hand if you look at male
behavior across different cultures it is
tremendously variable and it ranges from
you know simple provision of a paycheck
you know even in a country like Japan
where things that families are are
notoriously stable men play very little
role in the socialization and education
of their children but in other societies
they do in other societies they are the
primary you know in many respects
primary caregivers and the like but the
mere fact of that variability in male
behavior suggests that in fact the male
role is parent although it probably has
a national basis is to a much greater
extent than the woman's role socially
constructed one that is to say it is it
is based on all of the norms and laws
and and customs and moral pressures that
societies are able to bring to bear and
therefore it is not surprising that when
you get these technological developments
that relieve men in a certain sense of
the responsibility for children that
they will not find that a burden but
will actually take advantage of it and I
think that that is one of the things
that happen when we get to the issue of
trust there's a very complicated debate
that has emerged as a result of the
publication of Bob putnams article
Bowling Alone about what has been going
on in American civil society because he
argued that in fact civil society this
great took million American art of
Association that Tocqueville argued was
the bedrock of American democracy was in
decline because of the decline of a
number of important you know social
groups he points to the animal
organizations the Elks and Kiwanis and
moose and so forth that have had
steadily dropping numbers of adherents
but also the American Red Cross the Boy
Scouts League of Women Voters PTAs and
the like as well as poll data that
indicates that Americans simply do not
trust each each other or their major
institutions you know the nineteen late
nineteen fifty seventy percent of
Americans said they trusted the US
government to do the right thing most of
the time by the early 1990s that had
dropped to something like fifteen to
twenty percent and you know Americans
don't trust their fellow citizens either
there's a lot of survey data that that
indicates that
I think that the story of civil society
is actually much more complicated than
that because as a result of you know
Putnam published an article called
Bowling Alone because he said that
Americans are bowling in ever greater
numbers but they're not bowling in
bowling leagues they're bowling as
individuals and that this reflected the
general atomization of American society
I this set off a huge debate in which a
lot of social scientists argued back and
forth whether he was right just on the
empirical data and right in his
interpretation and I think that the
story that emerges having been I don't
want to bore you with all the details of
this but having been through all of that
it seems to me that he's probably not
right about groups and group memberships
that there you cannot prove that
Americans socialized with each other
less and in fact there's some evidence
that they're actually you know doing it
more in in some respects the problem was
trying to measure it as a social
scientist is that the newer groups never
keep statistics on themselves all the
you know aids support groups or Internet
chat rooms or you know whatnot and
therefore you're constantly being biased
in terms of looking at the older more
institutionalized groups but in fact
there is a fairly impressive set of data
that suggests that actually Americans
volunteer in in in you know to the same
extent that they did 30 40 years ago on
the other hand the decline in trust is
absolutely incontrovertible I know of no
serious you know survey data that that
shows the opposite and so the question
is how do you account for this because
presumably higher levels of trust and
participation in groups ought to be
positively correlated my explanation is
that what has been going on is a process
of what I call moral miniatures a ssin
that is to say people may socialize and
connect with each other to a greater
extent than ever before but the average
radius of trust the size of the groups
in which they participate has been
steadily getting smaller over time so
that a typical American in the 1940s or
50s would have been a member of a
Catholic parish or the Methodist or
Baptist Church would have been a veteran
of the US Armed Forces a member of the
afl-cio or some other
organization would have read The
Saturday Evening Post or Life magazine
watch The Ed Sullivan Show on the three
networks that were available the
grandson of that American is now in a
codependency support group or in an
Internet chat room or is watching one of
the channels on 500 channel cable TV
having gone to the aerobics Club which
is the primary source of social
interaction and so in a sense you know
what's happened is not that people
connect but that the connections tend to
be more transient the entry and exit is
much easier and therefore the kinds of
social relations that are established
are inevitably in a sense much more
superficial the internet which has been
certainly praised as a major social
transformative factor in American
society in a sense is a perfect epitome
of this moral miniaturization you can
use the internet to talk to all of the
other thirty people that want to grow
bonsai trees in the Upper Peninsula of
Michigan I mean the you know there'll be
a chat room that will allow you to do
that but you won't necessarily have
anything to say to the people in the
rest of Michigan that have that same
hobby because you simply won't be
talking to one another and in a sense
again this is something purely driven by
technology the fact that we have the
technology that connects us in so many
different ways in a sense has dissolved
the larger national conversations in
place of a whole lot of smaller ones I
actually had a student last summer that
wrote a paper on popular music since
genres of popular music are the primary
source of identification for American
teenagers it's actually a good measure
of the nature of American civil society
you see that perfectly there are no big
stars like you know Elvis Presley or the
Beatles anymore because the subgenres of
popular music have ramified into these
incredibly you know specialized ones and
I think that in a way that's you know
that's only one small part of American
society but it's emblematic of what's
been going on for the larger society now
let me conclude by just saying what I
think is next first of all I do not
believe that most traditionalist
conservatives that see this simply as a
straight line secular moral decline
can possibly be right in the first place
you've seen waves of social order and
disorder occurring before in the 19th
century if you looked at the same
indicators things like crime alcoholism
illegitimate see you would have seen in
both Britain and America
steadily rising rates of social
dysfunction in fact my favorite
statistic is in the late 1820s at the
height of American alcoholism you know
currently Americans drink something like
an average of about two gallons of
absolute alcohol per year there's some
social historians that think that the
per capita consumption in the year
eighteen 28 or 29 might have been 10
gallons so that all of these types of
social dysfunction rose every decade as
the country moved from an agrarian
society to an urban industrial one and
really picked up steam in the 1830s and
1840s on the other hand in every decade
after the year 1850 those same rates of
social deviants began to come down to
the point that by the end of the 19th
century they were virtually at the level
that they were in the year 1800 and that
was true for Britain as well as for the
United States which suggests that you
know there is also an important source
of social regeneration in most societies
as well as sources of of degeneration
if you look at the social statistics for
the 1990s it's actually hard not to be a
little bit optimistic as I'm sure you're
all aware crime rates have fallen
nationally at this point you know maybe
30 to 35 percent in a city that was
particularly plagued by violence like
New York the murder rate is now back to
where it was in the mid 1960s levels of
trust have not gone back but they having
they have improved so that for example
the number of Americans trusting the
federal government most of the time has
gone back up to about 20 let's say 25 to
30 percent the decline in in the family
has at least arrested itself so that the
the divorce rate had already started to
taper off in the 1980s the legitimacy
rate stopped rising and has actually
fallen a little bit since the mid
1990s and and so on and I think that you
know if you just look anecdotally at the
you know the culture around you there's
just no question that there's been a sea
change back to more socially
conservative attitudes in the 1990s and
it's really my generation I was born
smack in the middle of the baby boom it
seems to me that we're the ones that
caused all this great disruption in the
first place as we move through our teens
and 20s but now you know in fact I think
in that precise generation there's been
a huge innocence backlash against
excessive type of individualism and a
desire in a sense to recreate
communities so that on a community by
community neighborhood by neighborhood
basis there's been a huge effort on the
part of Americans to rebuild
neighborhood associations to clean up
you know parts that were infested with
drug dealers and to basically reclaim a
kind of social connection with other
Americans that I think is indicator is
an indicator that this in fact is a
transitional period that that reflects
the kind of technological and economic
pressures that were the result of this
transition out of the old industrial era
into something something very different
now the last little bit I will leave you
with has to do with the human nature in
my title because I think that there is
and what I would I guess label an
Aristotelian perspective on the way that
human beings are which is that you know
there are many sources of social order
of which religion and the state are two
that tend to be favored by conservatives
and by liberals respectively but in fact
there are other sources one example of
that is just a very humble and in a way
trivial one takes place in Washington DC
where I live there's a practice called
slugging I 95 is one of the most
congested arteries in the Washington
area if you live down in the southern
suburbs in Virginia and want to get into
downtown DC there are these things
called slug lines where you show up
outside of a restaurant in Springfield
and you hop into the car of someone that
you don't know and you ride on the HOV
lanes I guess
called commuter lanes here in the
Southland because their HOV 3 and that's
the way that you can shave about 40
minutes off of your round-trip commute
into downtown Washington now this is a
fascinating example of social order that
has coalesced simply spontaneously it
started during the oil crisis in the
1970s there was not a chief slug that
brought down the rules of slugging from
you know Mount Sinai that created this
system in a hierarchical way this simply
resulted in the interactions of
dispersed individuals that simply wanted
to get to work a little bit faster but
it's in fact a complete social system
there all sorts of rules you know you
can't talk about sex politics or a
religion you can refuse to get into the
car the you know anyone that you don't
particularly like and it's been a
remarkably orderly process there's only
been two crimes committed on slug lines
in the in the years since the mid-1970s
since they've been operating and as a
result you know no slug will allow
female slug to be on a slug line late at
night by herself and so in in a certain
sense you know it's an illustration of
the way that social order is simply the
result of people interacting as rational
individuals can create social rules for
themselves and I believe that in a sense
the future basis of social order really
has to depend on a lot of a lot of
different areas it's clear that the
state is not going to go away despite
the you know the dreams of certain
conservatives that's an extremely
important hierarchical source it is also
clear that religion will not disappear
and I mean that was an old story told by
a certain generation of social
scientists but it seems to me that the
desire for religious belief in community
is very deeply rooted in human beings
but there are also these innocent
spontaneous sources of order that
operate that constantly adjust to the
problems and the conditions that are
thrown up to us by our outside
environment and that I believe I don't
know I mean Charles will have to correct
me whether I'm getting my Aristotle
wrong or not but it does seem to me that
our Aristotle argued in a certain sense
that you know that human beings were
inherently or by nature a political and
social creature
that had a desire to live in society
with other people they were not the
isolated individuals of modern you know
economics or early modern theorists of
the state of nature but in fact were
born with a desire for social connection
and therefore they feel intensely
uncomfortable living in a hyper
individualistic society in which their
bonds to other people are greatly
attenuated and in that situation they
will try to recreate those bonds in any
way they can given the differences of
Technology and so forth and so while I
don't believe that the family for the
reasons I indicated will ever go back to
the situation of the 1950s it does seem
to me that families have and in fact are
in the process of becoming friendlier to
to the interests of of children and that
I think is the task of social order
building that lies ahead of us as we
move into this new century so thank you
very much I'd be happy to take any
questions that you have
legs once and they must be keanu we have
time for questions please come out of
this
let me ask you some questions about
miniaturization let me ask you some
questions about vineyards ization is it
is there a natural end to it a natural
limit to it is there an antithesis to it
is it a recursion to some previous moral
order well you know if you look at what
a natural moral order is you know it's
to live in a band of about you know 30
40 you know people most of whom you are
related to I mean that's natural
sociability and you know in a certain
sense and it's in in some sense
unnatural to live in a giant society of
you know 270 million people with all
these constitutional rules that prevent
you from hiring your your nephew or your
brother you know in an important
bureaucratic post so that nature gives
you you know certain directions about
what's you know what's natural but
they're not ones that are really
compatible with a lot of elements of the
you know the modern world I think the
problem with moral miniaturization is
that it's not satisfying in the long run
because it is a kind of superficial form
of moral connectedness and an Internet
chat room is a perfect example of that
real communities make entry and exit
difficult you look at the Plymouth or
jamestown settlements these people could
not get away from one another and
therefore they developed social rules to
interact and they developed you know
strong sense of obligation to one
another simply as a matter of survival
an Internet chat room is up the way far
end of the spectrum you can there's no
cost entering but there's also no cost
to leaving which is why you have flame
wars and instability instability that
you would not have in a face-to-face
kind of community now if that in fact is
the direction in which modern
technological communities are tending I
think people will not like that very
much they also you know the other aspect
of this is a multiplication of
identities because you know the fact
that you can join an NGO you can join a
chatroom you can you know be in a
professional association multiple
workplaces multiple families
all of that in the end means that the
you know that the commitments that you
make in any one of these groups is is is
is going to be shallower and I think
that there probably is a limit point at
which people will say no I want you know
something deeper than this and what form
that takes whether that leads to new
political movements that you know that
that give people identity but a you know
a much more powerful you know form of
the identity that you know that maybe
something that you know the lies in the
future small liberal arts colleges such
as this one know you're well above the
size of an average hunter-gatherer
Society so I think you're probably
you're probably safe
I wanted to see if we couldn't make some
small case for the Vietnam War in in
this the exceptions were pretty clear
Japan and Switzerland that you but forth
but in fact they were sort of
isolationist at that at that point of
course Switzerland for a very long time
but here was the youth of United States
which was you know the leader of the
West and they were you know unanimously
opposed to this war they know where the
cutting edge and they I would think they
influence the youth in other countries
as well no that's that's true there was
an international aspect to to Vietnam
that stimulated you know the events in
Paris in 1968 and a lot of and a lot of
other things I guess the the reason
though that I tend to distrust that kind
of argument is that if you look at you
know this whole collection of data the
the changes are so thorough going that
it really is hard to you know see how
Vietnam you know leads to these very
different practices and child rearing in
the way that you relate to you know old
people and then a whole lot of a whole
lot of other things and certainly the
exceptions are actually Japan and
Switzerland have relatively small state
sectors but the the two exceptions to
the general pattern of social disorder
the great disruption are Japan and Korea
which and you know Japan actually has
had a falling crime rate over this same
period virtually non-existent
illegitimate see you know it's only
slightly rising divorce rate which
indicates that culture still does
you know matter but on the other hand
this will be an interesting empirical
test because my prediction is that Japan
will actually follow the United States
and Canada and Britain and other
countries down this road Japan currently
has such a low birthrate that they are
going to essentially you know they're
going to lose
they're their absolute labor forces
actually started to decline a couple of
years ago they're gonna be so labor
short that they're gonna have two
choices either to let in foreigners or
to increase working women and right now
they have one of the lowest rates of
female labor force participation of any
industrialized country and my suspicion
is that they will prefer the latter to
the former and then it'll be a nice
social science experiment we'll meet
back in 25 years and see whether you
know whether they've gone through a lot
of the same you know changes that we
have incidentally they they have yet to
legalize the birth control pill in that
country
if the technical changes are the great
disruptors and are I think they are
occurring more quickly what's gonna stop
people from our societies drowning in
these continual changes they're coming
quicker and quicker well nothing I mean
we may drown that's a big problem it
seems to me that particularly since the
invention of the scientific method in
you know in early modern times we have
put ourselves on this technological
escalator that is probably getting is
probably getting faster but it's been a
problem that's been with us for the last
you know at least three or four
centuries I mean you know in many
respects I guess I'm a little hesitant
to say that the rate is is clearly
faster because if you think of the
changes that occurred in the United
States or other European countries
between the year 1850 and 1900 they
probably were you know at least as
dramatic as the ones that occurred
between the year 1950 and the year 2000
you know in 1850 these countries were
largely agricultural societies peasant
societies in the case of Europe by the
year 1900 they were mostly
industrialized urban you know and that
involved a huge disruption of you know
the norms of a village life the
discipline of sociology you know has
been described by one famous sociologist
as a long commentary on the transition
from Gemeinschaft to gesellschaft that
is to say from this or you know organic
you know village you know kinship based
society to a modern one
based on a rule of law and if you think
that was disruptive I mean you're right
because it was now the question for the
future you know there plenty of
technological changes that we can
anticipate right now the information
revolution as I indicated has already
had a significant social impact we have
a biotech revolution that I'm
particularly in a sense concerned about
because it affects much more fundamental
aspects of human behavior than than the
information revolution and that's
something that's only now you know
beginning to unfold and so you know we
may return to some kind of normality but
but we've got a lot of other great
disruptions I think in our future I'm
curious when you cool I'm curious when
you talk about the this the great
disruption and then the rebuilding of
social values if I'm not really clear on
whether you're talking about the simply
the reconstitution of past social values
or the construction of a new set of
social values for instance I think it'd
be a bad idea to back fellow from our
current music scene to Elvis Presley in
the Beatles but on a more serious note
on a more serious note night I doubt
that that most working women now would
be content to you know similarly settle
into the role of women that in the last
century okay it it depends on the aspect
of social order that that you pick I
don't see any reason why crime rates
could not be completely wound back to
the levels that we saw you know in the
early 1960s and that may well happen
over the next few years on the other
hand I think you're absolutely right if
if if I am correct in my analysis of why
these changes in the family happened and
there's no chance that we will ever go
back to you know those older forms and
that's I guess you know a respect in
which I think a lot of conservatives you
know haven't come to grips with the sort
of the technological and economic
underpinnings of the changes that that
have occurred because you know women are
not going to leave the workforce and
you're not going to uninvent the pill
and therefore you know the conditions
for you know the the
of the family and kinship that existed
prior to those you know those changes
simply will not come back and therefore
all of the readjustments that have to
take place have to take place in the
context of you know two working parent
families and this sort of thing recently
President Clinton has been making a big
push for the Internet to be the device
to bring up the lower poverty levels
recently he was in East Palo Alto wiring
schools and then he was in Navajo Indian
Reservation giving essentially free
phone service how do you see the lower
poverty levels accepting the Internet
and how do you see that I actually think
that this is a non-issue I mean frankly
you know there's a there's a fair amount
of evidence now that has indicated that
one of the major drivers of income
inequality or the you know the skewing
of income distribution in the United
States is in fact the progress of
technology that I guess one way to put
it is that computers allow you know
smart well-educated people to make off
like bandits and really increase their
productivity and everything you know
very rapidly whereas people that don't
have access to it don't don't get to do
that and therefore the initial impact of
computers has been to widen you know
levels of inequality rather than to
close them I suspect that this is
probably only a temporary condition
because one of the features of virtually
every communications technology that's
come along in the past century has been
a very rapid drop in price and a very
rapid social diffusion that would you
know it used to be that they thought
that telephones were primarily for rich
people to be able to ring their maids
and butlers and you know get them to
come you know come to work whereas now
you really can't imagine not having a
phone in in the United States and I
suspect that that you know the internet
and and personal computers will you know
become ubiquitous devices and a lot of
that will simply be driven by the market
that people will see that you know that
there are tremendous advantages to be
had and that will apply to poor people
as well and government policy may may at
the margins push
process along but I think that that's
that's something that will probably work
itself out you know over time um you
discuss the idea of having social groups
with easy entry and exit in a current
time and I was wondering uh with the
idea of you know globalization and you
know people like Robert Reich have
argued that the consequence of that is
symbolic analysts versus service
oriented jobs creates very independent
autonomous people and but he goes to the
extent to say that also makes them sort
of autonomous from their state and that
in that way sort of transcend the state
becomes something where they're you know
the large community of said by the
United States become sort of annihilated
in a sense in the long run do you agree
with that conception of the state or do
you feel like there's a different trend
going in that way I think it's certainly
the case that globalization tends to
undermine the you know the pull of the
state because it's inherently a
stateless you know the borders really
don't matter in terms of international
economic flows and so you do get this
cosmopolitan class that's very
comfortable moving across cultures and
languages and and different societies
and you know another group of people
that's completely rooted in a single
language culture region you know locale
and that the the gap between those is is
is very great this is what you know Tom
Friedman refers to as the distinction
between the lexis and and and the olive
tree and I think that you know one of
the problems is that the Lexus part of
the equation is intensely threatening to
the olive tree part because it first of
all it you know it can uproot the olive
tree I mean in a sense that
globalization can destroy jobs in a
traditional community you know because
it eliminates you know a particular
industrial sector in a particular you
know developing country and these people
that had intense social connections you
know now find themselves you know it
gets see and the like so I think that
you know that is one of the really
problematic elements of globalization
and incidentally it's one that applies
in developed countries as well I mean
the French feel you know they don't like
globalization because they feel that it
does not allow them to maintain the kind
of welfare
state that they you know that they would
like to have because you have all these
anonymous investors in the bond market
telling them that they have to cut back
on their their social spending and and
and that's their you know their sense of
community that's being being attacked by
that so I think that you know as we
proceed I I really don't see that
there's an alternative to globalization
but I do think that people have to be
you know aware of some of the social
costs of globalization and it's not
unreasonable to think that you know you
might want to slow down the process in
in certain ways because everybody will
have to adjust sooner or later but the
problem is that you know the process of
adjustment in itself is an extremely
difficult one it takes time it takes
human time not not computer time to do
this and therefore the you know social
policy has to be I think aware of that
good morning Jenna versus gizelle Shire
it takes a village to raise a child as a
hell of a big difference between a an
ephemeral catches catch can village
versus a stable personal village we've
been around for maybe 2 3 4 point 4
million years and through all of that
time we have lived under what I would
call personal circumstances personal
villages we can we're very adaptable we
live in tundra and deserts and so forth
we can go without air for forty-five
seconds or more more or less we can go
without water a little bit longer we've
got a lot longer I wonder how long we
can really go without living under more
personal circumstances well I agree it's
a it's a really big problem and I think
one of the problems that you know you
you essentially stripped out virtually
all elements of the village I mean it's
it's kind of ironic to talk about it
taking a village to raise a child
because in most American neighborhoods
once you get past the nuclear family
there isn't a village all there is is a
welfare bureaucracy and if that's the
kind of village you mean you know that's
that's something that's very you know
that's very problematic the
anthropologist Lionel Tiger says that
there's this new form of kinship that he
calls Bureau Gami which is basically
being married a woman being married to a
you know welfare agency and I think that
you know one of the aspects of social
life that that you need to hold on to is
the presence of people in a community
outside of the nuclear family that can
play a role in socialization for exam
that's where American residential
mobility I think in a certain sense is
very destructive in Europe they have
very high rates of family breakdown in
many neighborhoods but they don't have
as much crime and social pathology and I
think that one of the reasons is simply
that Europeans don't move around as much
as a man
so that even if the father isn't present
in the home there's still other you know
men in the neighborhood and other adults
you know that that can perform that that
socialization function and I think that
you know we celebrate our extremely free
and flexible labor markets I mean that's
one of the reasons we have 4.1 percent
unemployment versus you know
double-digit employment in many
continental European countries but part
of that you know we do I think pay a
certain social price for that great
mobility and flexibility in the sense
that you know all of the potential
villages that could you know still exist
you know are are under a lot of pressure
but even if you you know even the
European solution is not the one that
you know is ultimately all that
satisfying because they - I think face
the same you know lack of this personal
face-to-face contact and you try to make
up I think in terms of quantity what you
lack in you know in the quality of those
relations and that that may not be
satisfying I was curious about the
exceptions of Japan and Korea and
wondering why you think they were
impervious to you know these elements of
social disorder is it something in the
culture itself since they do have
origins you know outside of Western
civilization and also given that I mean
there's been a huge influence of
American culture in both of those
countries in the last couple decades can
they stay impervious or are they going
to just go the way that you know the
Western developed countries have well I
think as a cultural generalization all
Asian societies do not have anything
like Western modern Western
individualism you know that they're much
more communal societies in which a whole
series of communal institutions and and
in Chinese society particularly the
family remains extremely important and I
think that you know my view of why
they're so different from from other
societies is that you know basically
they remain pretty sexist that as I said
female labor force participation in both
countries is at the bottom of the OECD
range and anyone
you know lived in Japan knows that women
you know I mean there's a lot of
underemployment actually of women that
are officially employed and they still
have this M shaped labor force
participation curve where they go into
the workforce as young girls and then
get married and drop out you know and
raise families and come back in and so
forth and there's a lot of cultural
support for that and it's changed most
much less slowly then a lot of Japanese
feminists you know thought thought was
was likely Plus which social policy
there as in Germany actually supports
the incomes of male you know heads of
households and so there's a lot that
that bolsters that kind of that kind of
system but as I said my prediction is
that in fact it is going to change
because the same economic and
technological pressures are going to
apply to them but just you know maybe 10
or 20 years later than happened in in
the United States I back again I want to
say that I'm a great admirer of your
your books but I haven't yet read your
latest book so forgive me if this is
addressed in it I'll get to it after I
pass my classes but um I am I am curious
as to whether you feel that this the
sort of social reconstitution that you
see going on now and in the later part
of the of the 1990s is emblematic of a
sort of backpedaling to older social
values or of a construction of new
social values unique to this
post-industrial or informational age
because I don't feel like well as as I
said this seems to be a variant of your
earlier question yes I think I mean it
depends I mean you know respect for you
know simple laws about killing people
you know it seems to me are not gonna
change all that much and so you could
see a you know a resurrection of older
patterns of you know obedience to
Authority or respect for authority or
whatever but in other respects I think
you know the the the environment is
really very different and then so you
are gonna have just different kinds of
value I guess one example of this you
know it may be the case that you can
restore something of the integrity of
the household because if you think about
it the separation of work
and home life is entirely the product of
the Industrial Revolution you know prior
to that people lived on family farms
there wasn't you know the husband didn't
go off to an office or a factory you
know during the day now you know both
both parents do but it may be the
technology will permit you know
rejoining of those two locales I mean as
it has for a lot of people that now you
know work out of out of their homes so
there are a lot of possibilities which i
think do involve not you know simply
turning the clock back but but really
doing things differently
yes Studs Terkel
recently Minh maintained that ageism
which I call so now age discrimination
is all too pervasive it is more
pervasive than racism gender ISM and
homophobia it's it's a well-known fact
that so many of us past 40 is out of the
employment and they have a very
difficult time trying to get reemployed
and with that in mind is it very unusual
there that the creme de la creme of the
employment force in Silicon Valley would
have no loyalty at all but make a while
they will have the Sun shines and also
what do you think about these baby
boomers as they need more money
thanks to inflation and all other
expenses so what is going to be the
future you know there's gonna be a lot
of major social changes that will come
about as a pure result of these
demographic changes that are taking
place according to the United Nation
populations office low estimates for
population growth in industrialized
countries the median if you if you carry
those calculations out based on current
trends the median age in a country like
Italy in the year 2050 is going to be 58
in Germany it'll be 54 in Japan it'll be
53 or you know something like so half
the population will be you know will be
older than that and you know with with
better health care obviously people are
going to be a
to work too much later ages than than 65
they already can for all practical
purposes now in public policy this has
been seen largely as a social security
problem which it clearly is I mean
there's a huge social security liability
as the dependency ratio in all of these
Asian countries goes up but there are a
whole series of social problems that we
haven't even begun to address for
example the fact of this kind of normal
succession of people by generations as
you get older you can't any longer take
for granted because you may have you
know three four five generations alive
simultaneously this is important for
tenured university faculty because
they're not going to be getting out of
the way anytime soon and you know in the
future with with with you know with
health care and so it seems to me that
you're you are gonna have a rise in
intergenerational conflict whereas there
you know there had been a certain you
know sequence and a certain accepted you
know pattern for how one generation was
succeeded by another those rules are
gonna have to change and then the other
thing that you you alluded to this you
know with longer working lives and with
the increasing importance of human
capital the idea that you can go to
school in your early 20s and complete an
education and have that be the the skill
base that you will use for the rest of
your working life as you move up a
single job ladder is just you know is
not gonna work
it's already not work for all of these
countless you know 50-year old middle
managers that have been downsized out of
corporate you know jobs and I think what
that means ultimately is this idea that
you pursue a single you know status and
an income ladder your whole life without
ever rewinding and dropping down to a
lower rung isn't gonna work anymore the
people are going to have to get used to
the fact that you know you retire from
one job at age 55 and you retrain and
you go to work at a lower pay and
and with lower status somewhere else and
again that's a big adjustment that I
think you know nobody has really begun
to make yet I have a question about
class and how it relates to your
analysis I think you suggested but
didn't go into too much detail in your
analysis that some of these social
dysfunctions happen at all class levels
I wonder if you could speak more about
that and also address how class might be
influenced in the future well there is a
class dimension particularly to the
account of you know the breakdown of the
American family because if you look at
who was gaining jobs in the female labor
force in this you know this whole period
you know the vast majority of them were
women in the you know the bottom half of
the income distribution and I think that
actually a great deal of the instability
in the family actually came about in
working-class families which were being
hit in two directions that the the man
were losing you know well-paying factory
jobs in autos or steel or in you know
all those Rust Belt
industries while their girlfriends or
wives were actually finding him you know
a lot of employment and in service
sector kinds of jobs in Walmart's or
banks or or things like that and you
know given I mean the general economic
theory of the family I mean that's a you
know that's a real formula for you know
for trouble and I believe actually that
one of the problems in modern feminism
is that you know in a certain sense the
you know the games from women going to
work in terms of self-esteem and
independence and all those other things
we're much less great for people in the
bottom half of the distribution that is
to say a woman that would have stayed
home with her children and helped
educate and raise them you know it's now
is working for minimum wage at
McDonald's or a Walmart not seeing her
children you know having to find
alternative sources of care it's not
very satisfying the problem is that all
of the books
and the feminist movement is not written
by that kind of woman they're written by
by you know women in the top half of the
distribution that are lawyers or editors
or you know people that have actually
done you know extremely well and so I
think there's a you have to combine
class and gender I think in in these
different ways you know to really
understand part of part of what was
going on there or one more question
Aristotle talks very briefly in the
Nicomachean ethics about the difficulty
of friends remaining friends when
they're physically separated for a long
period and that leads rather naturally
to a question about the implications for
social capital of more and more social
interaction being done over screens of
one kind or another whether it's
teleconferencing or the cellular phone
or simply internet conversation as
opposed to personal conversation or even
voice conversation so I just like to see
what where you would take that one
speech that I give on that on that topic
no it's it seems to me you're you know
you're absolutely right that you know
there's a kind of technologist take on
this which just says you know you hook
everybody up with enough bandwidth and
and that creates social interaction but
I think that you know the truth of the
matter is that the deeper forms of
social action interaction are based on
reciprocity you know that is to say not
just having things in common you know
interest and so forth but actually you
know the exchange of favors that is
really the basis of friendship and a lot
of that really has to be done you know
face to face Plus which there are all
sorts of just cognitively a lot of clues
that you get about the trustworthiness
and character of other people that you
really only get by by direct contact and
so that's why actually paradoxically
airline travel has not gone down as the
Internet has expanded it's actually gone
up in tandem because the electronic
connections I think stimulate also a
greater need for you know for
face-to-face connections I think the
important
that is not ever going to disappear
McKenna College in thanking professor
Fukuyama